hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent game to share with you from
the 1996 European Club Cup on the white
end Boris gelfand
and he's playing against Vladimir
kramnik
this one has one of the most beautiful
finishes to a game you'll see a very
nice final move by kramnik
and I think it's this finish to the game
that can easily overshadow the
positional components that surface
throughout the opening and middle game
phases
is this early positional struggle that
sets the stage for the Beautiful Finish
it's a 28 move game very high level play
by both sides
primarily
um mostly cram next play is exceptional
as you'll see when I share the tale of
the tape very high accuracy
of kramnik's final 12 moves 11 of them
are the top line by stockfish
now this positional struggle I speak of
I'm going to give you one piece to pay
close attention to throughout this game
and that is
kramnik's King Knight take note of the
great care it's given throughout
on board we have a slob defense
E6 now signals the semi-slave
E3 Knight B D7 and queen C2 this is
noted as the Stoltz variation
gelfand is staying clear of the mainline
mirin variation
Mainline mirin would run with Bishop D3
after the bishop has moved take on C4
and then look to play on the queen side
a few ways to continue from here this is
a very sharp line
in playing Queen C2 we can say the king
Bishop remains uncommitted for at least
another move
white is saying if you do want to
release the tension I'm happy to
recapture in one go and in these lines I
prefer having my queen on C2 rather than
home base
black has no interest in capturing on C4
continues to develop
Bishop D6 where it supports an E5 Pawn
break
and now in comes G4 this is noted as the
shabal of attack
before I share anything more I'm going
to throw a pop quiz your way and ask how
would you reply to White's last move
feel free to pause the video and think
about it for a little bit
okay I'd like to devote some time to
this moment in the game it's important
there are a few ways you could be
replying to White's last move first of
all
when is this move played exactly it's
played when
the king Bishop has been developed or in
other words as soon as
the G7 Pawn is unprotected
so one of the options black has is to
take the pawn another is to play H6
another is to take on C4
what does kramnik play we're gonna see
soon enough
let me touch on these moves if you're
taking on G4 certainly things are
opening up on the king side this is one
of the lines
you may see
King side castles probably not going to
be happening in this game for black
with the g-puns
uh with there not being a g Pawn around
very Dynamic play from there another H6
what's that doing stabilizing the king
Knight for another move or two at the
same time do know that castling King's
side is a little bit risky as well in
these situations with the pawn on H6
this can act as a hook
so it may take a little bit more time
for white to prep
upon Advanced to G5 but when it does hit
it's going to hit that much harder and a
file will be cracked open
that third move capturing on C4
what is black saying I'm giving up my
biggest pawn my strongest Pawn in order
to vacate D5
for my king Knight
so in the event of G5 the Knight goes to
the center
now if your mentality in this position
was to ignore White's last move and just
carry on with castles that's not a good
mentality to have and here's why
after G5 your knight has to go to a
square it doesn't like
it doesn't like E8
it's not productive there no wonderful
prospects to enter back into play
and if you go to H5 I must admit that
sometimes this could be an effective
post for the night
sometimes
it does a good job in stopping this Pawn
from getting to H5 and if the pawn can't
get to H5 there's pretty much not going
to be a pawn break
it could be effective in stopping Pawn
breaks however
posted on H5 in this situation is not
good for two reasons one it's not stable
there's a light Square Bishop still
around that could question it in two it
lacks a clear path back towards the
center
it doesn't have access to for example
the F4 Square
has no good squares at the moment and if
you're thinking well I could create a
path with G6 fiend Kettle the Knight hop
into F5 that is too far-fetched and too
weakening especially with still all
pieces on board to create these giant
gaps on H6 and F6 that's not a good way
to go
so
some care needs to be taken over this
King night
immediately as soon as G4 is on board
what is kramnik's choice
take the Knight or excuse me take the
pawn
H6
or C4 his choice
none of the above
this is not considered a best move
but it is certainly playable
with Bishop to G4 what is kramnik saying
maybe one of the first things he's
saying is I don't want to give up my
strongest Pawn on D5 you know I'm not
not going to go with d takes C4
I am also prepared to give up my good
Bishop
for a night
this is always one of those proceed with
caution type ideas you could be in this
case black could be especially
vulnerable on the dark squares
and another point in playing Bishop to
B4 kramnik saying I still want to keep
my king side as a safe haven for my king
I'm not going to move any of these pawns
I'm not going to allow the king side to
be opened up so easily
okay
now in playing Bishop to B4 what is
black prepared to do as mentioned he's
prepared to give up Bishop for Knight
what is being accomplished with this
well you're eliminating a defender of E4
so that the king Knight
can make use of that square right now
you know I didn't point this out but
after Castle's here we can't hop into
the center we don't have enough support
for that
so he's trying to eliminate a key
defender of E4 for the king Knight
from here we have Bishop to D2
Queen E7
and now in comes A3
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes Bishop
now at the end of the game when I share
the tail the tape this A3 move
does not
register as a mistake nor does it
register as an inaccuracy it is a more
minute error
considered better is G5 both A3 and G5
in this position are provoking Bishop
takes Knight
and it is better
to get in G5 G5 we could say
is more consistent
you play G4 to play G5 to scare the
Knight or maybe
more so just take over control of F6
from additional pieces
and G5 is also less weakening in a way
in playing A3
you know when you're playing the shabal
of attack with G4 your intention is to
Castle a queen side it is better for
white to keep keep these pawns on B2 and
A2
so there's even you know ideas to
continue rushing down with h4h5 G6 so G5
is more consistent on this move nine a
little bit better than A6
this is where it now sort of
turns evenish in playing A3 rather than
G5
okay Bishop takes Knight follows
Bishop takes Bishop
and this is the first
moment where black
is now on move and is having to deal
with an unopposed dark Square Bishop so
what does he go with not castles
he goes with V6 immediately looking to
control dark squares
black already has in mind
not just the bishop development to B7 or
A6
but he's staying strong on C5 so if the
bishop tries to go elsewhere
be irritating to the queen stop castles
there is now a good reply in C5
okay
from here Bishop D3
E4 is no longer an option G5 right
around the corner what is kramnik going
to do
how to react to this
is Play Bishop A6
a move played on the queen side is
having an influence on this
Center Square E4
black is prepared to distract one of
these pieces
from observing E4 because of this
pressure on C4
now the move played in the game
is Queen A4
if the Knight is attacked
how can black reply
by capturing on C4 it's turning out
that in in this line blacks d-pawn
would
be hungrier than White's g-pawn there's
more more stuff in the black in the in
the black ponds way so how might this go
Chop on C4 F6 something like this blacks
for Choice it's up upon both of these
probably end up getting picked up but
black is up a pawn in this position
doing very well
there is no G5 here
Bishop A6
is met with Queen A4 so already this
move has had an influence on that King
Knight
had an influence on the E4 Square it's
pulling the queen away from watching
over E4 indirectly
the reply here
couple of different ways you could take
on C4
kramnik goes with the better
D takes C4
if you're capturing with the bishop on
C4 this is not good
because after Bishop takes Pawn takes
there's Queen takes C6 and Black's
reaction must now be a strictly
defensive one
there is a thread on The Rook
considered best as Queen to d8 that is
very awkward
if you
simply Castle connecting Rooks
remember that unopposed Bishop
it strikes
that's a problem
this is winning for white
what is the difference in capturing on
C capturing on
C4 with the pawn rather than the bishop
well if let's say queen takes C6 in this
position the bishop is still around
and now there's a nice counter attack to
the thread Against The Rook
Rook C8
white is forced back and white in this
position now has to make a strictly
defensive move
black has with this sequence bought
himself sometime
to make a productive move so the bishop
is hit
the Knight is hit white has to fall back
like this and you may find it
interesting to note
in this position the top two moves by
black are Knight D5
and A5
what is similar
with these two moves well or what is
common with these two moves they are
taking into account the unopposed dark
Square Bishop they're watching over this
bishop to B4 move
okay
kramnik takes with a pawn that is the
better capture
Queen takes Bishop Pawn takes Bishop
Queen takes Pawn
and finally kramnik's ready to Castle
from here G5 where do we go
to the edge go to the center
we go to the center
it's still not good to go to the edge
there isn't a light Square Bishop around
but where is that clear path back
towards the center it still isn't there
okay
on board Knight D5
if the Knight is given a kick
it's going to take the bishop so Bishop
D2 first nearby
is E4 what is kramnik going to do about
the Knight
after E4
now I should know
been drawing a lot of attention to this
knight jump onto that H5 Square suppose
instead of playing G5 straight away
what if white played E4
and then after C5 let's say went with G5
is now an okay time to go to H5
yes
so I want to highlight this
because now
this is an effective Square for the
night why there isn't a bishop around
that can question it and it now has a
clear path back towards the center
F4 is available
there isn't a convenient defender of f4
upon would be a convenient Defender
okay
in the game we have G5
Knight D5 Bishop D2
moments away the knight's gonna be
questioned but kramnik of course alert
to that he plays F5 looking to stabilize
the Knight and it will in this game
remain stable it took a lot of effort
where 16 Moves In
this Pawn will be around to watch out
for E4 Black's ready to take on e4 if
that's on board
and the Knight will stay there
notice
this is a losing move for white taking
on F6 on poisson
because after Queen takes there's a big
problem on the f-file
now at first glance I thought white is
either going to lose a piece straight
away
or Black's going to be capturing on F2 a
check and White's going to be dead
I found a fun little line like to
highlight here
there is E4 kicking the Knight
defending the Knight once
well I could continue like this to save
the night but there's always these
tricks we got knights around and the
white king is still in the center here's
one fun way you could end up winning
some material Queen sakes night is a
nice tactical shot at this stage
Queen takes Queen Knight D4
black wins a piece
okay
F5
capturing nf6 is losing for white so
Queen side castles
where to go from here well opposite
sides castling let's try and open up
some lines the king is on the C file
so let's try and get rid of the C Pawn
C5 on board
King B1 very natural
ready to get the Rook on the C file pop
quiz
Can you spot kramnik's next move as
mentioned at the start of the video
kramnik was hitting
you know 11 of his remaining 12 moves of
this game
Top Line by stockfish
this next one is a top one
Can you spot it feel free to pause the
video
okay best move
B5
very very nice move
um
some note you may want to make to
yourself
in positions like these right here as
soon as if you're playing as black
let's say and your opponent goes Queen
side castles here's one quick note you
could say to yourself we have opposite
sides castling
another note my opponent's king
is on the queen side
and when my opponent's king is on the
queen side there is a pawn of mine that
is expendable
if your opponent's king is on the queen
side your queen Knight Pawn is upon I
like to consider expendable
so it's the B Pawn in this case that you
would really prefer to not have on the
board
and the reason for that is because
without that guy around
black has the potential to stack the
Rooks on the B file where it aims right
at the heart of the enemy King position
it is a very small Pawn a very small
investment
you know you're giving up one point
in playing B5 it is captured in this
case you're giving up one point in order
to activate 10 points towards the enemy
king that's a that's a good investment
material not a big deal
very often in these opposite sides
castles positions
so this is how the game followed the
Queen the Queen picked up the bee Pawn
some other options like I don't know
capturing this Pawn in this position not
good either improving us seventh ranked
night
to improve two ranks
with Force generating a threat
These Are Monsters
if this Pawn is not captured in this
position let's say white carries on with
play on the king side
now comes C4
and here here's how quickly things could
just be smashed open
there's already C3
Here Comes B4
this is not savable for what the
position is now broken
on the queen side and there's no
guarantee any of these moves are
getting white anywhere there's no
guarantee of an open file
H6 G6
excuse me g6h6 and H6 G6 it's locked up
files won't open up
so
it's going to be a tall task ahead for
white to try and defend this position he
ends up taking the pawn
in comes Rook a B8 Queen A5
this is the only sub-optimal move
kramdic makes kramnik makes for the
remainder of the game
hard to argue with it though it seems
perfectly natural
he goes as deep as he can with the Rook
to a gap
right here it is a hole on B3 observing
two pawns pinning a pawn to a night it's
unprotected on F3
considered better is one of the better
moves is Rook B6 or C4 even
where this this Pawn looks to be
uh become a battering ram
I guess in a way you're stopping this
knight from ever making use of D4
but okay C4 was considered one of the
better moves here but who could argue
with Rook to B3
from here King to A2
very natural looking Type move
you know you're getting out of a pin
you're watching over both of these pawns
maybe there's some fancy capture on A3
the king is watching over that a little
bit more
um it is not considered best though best
is King A1
so why maybe not go to A2 this feels
very natural to me so I had a you know I
just kind of questioned my own mentality
here
in playing King to A2 yes you're out of
the PIN
you're threatening The Rook but it's not
an inconvenience it's not as if when you
play King to A2 it's an inconvenience to
Black Black's going to double the Rooks
anyway so
there's really no
well you know black is an inconvenience
by stacking the Rooks next
the more I looked at it I thought oh you
know what when you're on A1 yes you're
out of the PIN
and now there's only two Poss there's
only one check in the position that's
that's the way I looked at it there's
only one check Rook takes A3
not saying it's a great move but one
check compared to
four checks one two three four maybe
it's better to go to a square where you
could only be checked once
however weird the check may seem
you never know how the position is going
to
evolve and the complications that may
arise so
okay in this game it's King A2
black doubles the Rooks
it's not fun but white has to babysit
the bee Pond somehow or it could be one
and now in comes E5 very strong move
best move
uh the only move I believe that wins
is E5 clearing the way for Queen E6
trying to get on this diagonal
Rook H C1 Queen E6 it is setting up
discoveries
so this rocks the king back
to A1
um you may
find it interesting you know why are we
going to
E6 rather than F7
well from F7 you're not stable
you could be hit with G6
if you're capturing there's Knight G5 so
there's some irritating moves if your
queen is on F7 rather than the more
Central and stable E6
from here King A1
and now how to capture on D4 do we
follow the general rule of taking
towards the center
not in this case
we go with e takes D4 we have a reason
to stay away from the general rule
it's a very computer-ish line I'd like
to highlight it
if you're capturing towards the center
there's some deep line with G6
H6 cutting that out
and now Queen to A4
and now all of a sudden let's say after
this move there's this idea where this
Rook could pivot on C6 and distract the
queen kick her off of this diagonal
it's a
it's a bit of a loose position all of a
sudden for black it's considered even
okay it's a very computer-esque uh line
right there
you don't really have to see that line I
don't believe though in playing Black's
next move
black can say to himself I have a good
reason to not go with the general rule
of taking towards the center
notice what's happening if you're taking
towards the center
you could just look at it from a numbers
standpoint
look at the
new options you would be giving the
white pieces when you're taking towards
the center
the queen now has access to D5 that's an
additional legal move
and also this Rook has access to C6 C7
C8 maybe there's some lines I can't
share a line with you but
in some other type of position maybe
Landing a key check
distracting this B8 Rook from the B file
is something
those options aren't available
too white when you're taking with the
epon
anyhow important to note that there is a
nice exception to this general rule in
this case has to do with the mobility of
the white pieces not extending
not increasing the mobility of the white
pieces okay
from here it's Rook takes C5 hard to
suggest something at this stage for
white
he's trying to knock out the defender of
D4 so that there's this Fork that can
land but
this one's over for white and it
finishes in a beautiful way as mentioned
at the start
Rook takes Pawn
Knight takes Rook
blacks up a rook there's no time to land
the fork now
because we could just duck off for a
queen Exchange
blacks up The Rook
so first is Queen takes Knight
and now
here we go remember the great care that
kramnik has given this King Knight
in the middle game uh opening in Middle
game now it drops
an absolute bomb on the position to
quite a quite a lot of work for this but
Knight C3 lands this is a big
intersection Square
clearing the way for some Queen A2 idea
a lot of different mating ideas for
black at this stage
how to react to this there really isn't
a
a good way if you're capturing
with the bishop
you're inviting another Pawn into the
mix B2 is going to collapse
so let's have a look at this line
actually if now Knight to D4
you could take on B2
Brook takes B2 and in this line you
could afford to give up your queen
here's one of the fun ways this one
could go straight to mate
it's pretty
okay move played in the game is not
Bishop takes Knight but Knight takes D4
Landing the fork
in comes
Rook takes B2 very nice you could afford
to give up
the queen there are two different mates
on A2 so Knight takes Queen we have this
mate
or even just Rook takes beat Rook takes
B1
move played in the game The Rook takes
B2 I should mention there's this funny
move
in this position as white instead of
taking on B2 if you play Queen f8
you can't capture with the King
white would end up winning
you don't want to lose your queen with
check so
you know if this flashy move was on
board
by gal fandang this move 28 you would
take with the rook and be winning
anyhow funny
Spike check I guess we could say
in the game it's Rook takes B2 and one
final move to this one can you spot it
what is kramnik's last move of this game
feel free to pause the video
okay here we go
Queen A2 and white resigns very flashy
finish there's only one legal move
Rook takes Queen would run into Rook B1
for me
that King Knight
is amazing it took a lot of work but
the positional ideas are what led up to
this tactical finish and
uh definitely a beautiful finish to this
28 mover
anyhow let's have a look at
the tail the tape on this one we could
see
the level of play super high
and 86 and 86 for galfan 97 for kramnik
a very nice game very instructive game
been staring at this one for several
hours now and I feel I
grew somewhat as a player in reviewing
this one game so
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye